you don't know about real loss because
that only occurs when you love something
more than you love yourself I doubt
you've ever dared to love anybody that
much and I was back there uh recently
and I went back to that bench is you
know it's it's all it's right in there
in the Boston Commons and I walked over
there with my family and we sat on the
bench and you know the kids didn't know
they've never seen the movie they're too
young but it was nice to go back and
think about him back there I can't learn
anything from you I can't read in some
[ __ ] book unless you want to talk
about you
who you are and I'm fascinated was it
before during her after you knew that
this was just a really special moment I
think it was while we were shooting it
you know because I don't I didn't have I
had probably one or two lines in that
whole scene it was it was Robin scene
and when he was just crushing it you
know on the first take yeah I just went
this is this is going to be really good
yeah you know this is going to be really
good chief